from hearing loss to spinal injuries to
painful stunts gone wrong some actors
have suffered lasting consequences for
the sake of making their art
in 2016 production on the final chapter
in The Maze Runner series was suspended
indefinitely due to horrific onset
accident involving Dylan O'Brien the
franchise's young Stars sustained severe
brain trauma when a stunt involving a
motorcycle went very wrong O'Brien
effectively needed to have his face put
back together by a skilled
reconstructive surgeon the actor told
the Salt Lake Tribune I have four plates
that will be a part of me forever I feel
really lucky to have come away from it
in terms of coming away from it at all
on the day and really how my face has
healed I was really lucky with a really
brilliant doctor and he salvaged a lot
of what I used to look like I think it's
really astonishing how well everything
healed and how my dog does fixed me up
after a bit of a break to heal up
O'Brien got back to work in Hollywood
but his traumatic experience left him
with some lasting worries in 2020 he
told variety even to this day if I'm on
set and I'm doing a stunt if I'm in a
rig if there's some action going on I am
slightly irritable there is a degree of
anxiety in me that I don't think there's
ever not going to be
Natalie Portman puts herself on a strict
diet and lost 20 pounds to play the part
of fragile ballerina Nina sayas in
Darren aronofsky's dark drama Black Swan
she wasn't the only one to take a method
of prose her character though her
co-star Mila Kunis followed suits but
didn't get nearly as much attention for
her transformation she told radio host
Howard Stern I used to be a smoker and
so I smoked a lot of cigarettes they ate
a limited amount of calories 1200
calories and I smoked I don't Advocate
this at all it was awful cunis later
revealed that her body has never
returned to the states it was in before
preparations for Black Swan began she
told Harper's Bazaar my shape is
different when I got down to 95 pounds I
was muscle like a little brick house but
skin and bones when I gained it back it
went to completely different areas I
will never dance again I promise you I
will never put on that point shoe ever
again in a candid 2018 interviewed the
New York Times Uma Thurman shared some
Revelations about director Quentin
Tarantino during the production of Kill
Bill Tarantino reportedly forced Thurman
to perform a dangerous driving scene
that left her with lasting damage she
told the times I was scared he said I
promise you this car is fine as a
straight piece of road hit 40 miles per
hour or your hair won't blow the right
way and I'll make you do it again but
that was a death box that I was in the
seat wasn't screwed down properly it was
a sand road and it was not a straight
road Thurman lost control of the Carmen
gear and it veered off the road crashing
into a tree and leaving her in so much
pain that she feared that she had lost
her ability to walk for good while it
wasn't as bad as she initially feared
the accident left her with lasting
injury to her neck and knees the
accident is part of the reason that
Thurman had also starred in Tarantino's
Pulp Fiction hasn't worked with the
director since Kill Bill vol 2.
Wolverine the adamantium claw wielding
member of the super heroically mutated
X-Men is one of the most pronounced and
famous Grumps in all of popular culture
every iteration of the character
imprints on the small screen and in a
series of feature films spanning two
decades has been depicted as a scowling
grumbling tough guy who ultimately
mutters dialogue in a raspy mutter or
angry shout no one has played Wolverine
more often than Hugh Jackman who has
struck the claws and taken on that
distinctive voice in nine X-Men Universe
movies between 2000 and 2016. seven
years after last playing the role
Jackman revealed that his voice and
vocal chords still suffer from the
consequences of that iconic voice he
told BBC Radio 4's front row in 2023 my
teacher at drama school would have been
horrified by some of the things I did in
Wolverine I've done some damage to my
voice through playing Wolverine
specifically Jackman has said that when
he performs in musicals he finds that he
can't reach the high notes the way he
once did he continued I put that down
directly to some of the growling and
yelling I did
ah
the fishiest star of the DC Universe may
look like an unbeatable impossible to
hurt superhero but Jason Momoa is only
human after the first Aquaman movie
became a global box office sensation in
2018 Warner Brothers quickly ordered a
sequel Aquaman and the lost kingdom
throughout the filming of the physically
demanding and stunt heavy action movie
Momoa suffered for his art chalking up
his vulnerability to his advancing age
the actor told Ellen DeGeneres I'm
getting old I messed up my eyes I just
got something in it that kinda cut it up
and then I've got to get surgery I have
a hernia I've got ribs out I'm just
getting beat up in addition to what he
confirmed as a scratched cornea and
hernia Mamoa revealed to Yahoo that he
wound up with a facial scar after a
fight scene in the 2018 movie Braven
went sideways he recalled I got knocked
out a stun guy hit me he blindsided me
we didn't make eye contact and he hit me
before I could grab for him and
everything went black Mamoa required
hospitalization for the incident and
shooting on Braven was put on hold for a
day
after breaking into stardom with her
role as vanon fx's award-winning dramedy
Atlanta zazi Beast was suddenly being
offered work in movies much bigger than
the shorts and Indies in which she was
used to performing in 2018 she
co-starred in the big budget superhero
comedy Deadpool 2 as Domino a member of
the titular Heroes X-Force of powerful
Rogues Domino's special power she's
extremely lucky luck isn't a superpower
yes it is no it isn't yes no man Mario
Lopez yeah life did not imitate art on
the set of Deadpool 2 unfortunately
according to USA Today the film was a
physically grueling experience for the
actors with Beats training for four
hours a day for months before filming
began that was far from the worst part
though as things would continue to go
wrong for her once rehearsal ended
drawing one action sequence that
involved a high-speed truck Chase beats
lost Consciousness and drawing an
elaborate fight scene a stray case thing
from a freshly fired shell landed on her
chest burning her skin and leaving a
permanent scar
our free would it agreed to take on the
role of 21st century spacecraft Builder
Lily Sloan in the 1996 film Star Trek
first Contact because she was friendly
with several members of the curse
including Brent Spiner LeVar Burton and
a specially director Jonathan Frakes a
pivotal scene called for a massive
explosion when the enemy Borg sends a
ship into the past which slums into
Earth and sends many of the good guys
flying what did recalls practicing the
sequence for many hours in which she and
a number of stunt performers with a jump
as if they've been knocked into the air
spin around and the land so the cameras
could capture their reactions would have
told collider the explosion was so
intense It just knocked us off our butts
we just fell any way we could at that
point wouldn't realize she'd torn up a
costume and her arms were covered in
blood Frank's got his shots but wooded
still bear scars on both of her arms
from the stunt a lot can go wrong on a
movie set even on a relatively low-tech
comedy case in points in 1986 Steve
Martin along with Martin Short and Chevy
Chase starred in the action tennis
comedy Three Amigos and this goofy
Romper 3 sound volunteera Western film
Styles get stuck in a terrorized Mexican
Village and have to save its residents
who think they are the brave Heroes who
play in the movies and not the spoiled
and cowardly actors they really are
Martin's character Lucky Day deals with
a number of uncomfortable situations to
which he's unsuited including several
shootouts that may have led to a case of
tinnitus a persistent high-pitched and
creating ringing of the years the actor
and comedian has suffered from the
condition ever since the production of
Three Amigos but he thinks something
else could have triggered it he told
Pitchfork in 2015 I was shooting The
Three Amigos and I got tinnitus I blamed
it on the gunfire at the time but since
then I realized it was just my destiny
after listening to music too loud my
whole life and playing live concerts
with 28 000 screaming people it was like
being in a football stadium
living with a six-year-old thankfully
Martin has learned to live without us he
continued it becomes your natural
background noise
while making 2013 saw the Dark World
Jaime Alexander who played Thor's Ally
Sith suffered a painful sounding injury
speaking with MTV News Alexander
explained that she had slipped and
fallen from an unfortunate height
elaborating I herniated a disc in my
thoracic spine dislocated my left
shoulder tore my right rhomboid and
shipped 11 vertebrae Alexander thought
the injury might not be a big deal but
the next morning it was still pretty bad
and then it got worse she continued I
got to the car to go to the hospital and
I sat in the car and compressed my spine
a little bit and when paralyzed in my
right leg and my right hand after a
month of physical therapy Alexander was
back on set swinging a sword but spinal
injuries like that don't just go away
entirely it seems like playing an
Asgardian might not be all it's cracked
up to be
Blake Lively's 2016 hits the shallows
proved that she had some genuine action
chops and the actor was duly rewarded
with the lead role in her very own spy
Thriller the Rhythm Section sadly things
went South for lively in late 2017. as
an onset injury she sustained while
filming an action sequence with Jude Law
course of film to hold production
sources informed The Hollywood Reporter
that Lively's hand injury wasn't thought
to be all that serious at first but the
surgery she underwent after sustaining
it apparently failed to fix the issue
further surgeries followed with both
Paramount and Lively awaiting
instructions from surgeons on how best
to proceed in early 2018 she was cleared
to return to the set filming resumed
later in the year but Lively's hand
never quite returned back to the way it
was before I suffered a ligament here so
my knuckles were kind of dropped and
then I you know dislocated these two
bones in The Wizard of Oz the Beloved
1939 thermal adaptation of L frank
bomb's fantasy novel Jack Haley played
the Tin Man The Friendly metal monster
on his way to see the wizard to acquire
a heart however Haley wasn't mgm's first
choice for the role or even the first
actor cast according to Vanity Fair
Buddy Ebsen best known for his later
leading gigs on The Beverly Hillbillies
and Barnaby Jones was hired first when
rehearsing in makeup and under studio
lights the crew repeatedly covered
epson's face with aluminum dust to keep
his white grease paint from running one
night's during the rehearsal period
Epson awoke with painful cramps in his
limbs his face had turned blue and he
couldn't breathe the actor spent two
weeks of hospitalization in an oxygen
tent his body had to divest itself of
the large amount of toxic aluminum
sitting in his lungs with his recovery
taking longer than they liked MTM fired
Epson and installed Haley instead
another cast member of The Wizard of Oz
also experienced a severe medical
reaction Ray Bulger portrayed the
brightness scarecrow and on the final
day of shooting he took off his Rubber
and burlap base prosthetic mask for the
last time when he did he discovered that
he had received burlap like scars all
over his chin and mouth
foreign